the american league takes on the
national league with a seven-game win
streak on the american left side they've
won seven in a row of course we skipped
last year but going back to 2019 and
before that you have to go back to 2012
the last time the national league took
down the al that was the game when the
nl lineup blitz justin verlander early
on honoring the late hank aaron his
widow billy mrs billy aaron is on the
field
they have hank aaron's number they have
a portrait of hank aaron out there as
well hank aaron lost this past year uh
for one of many major league baseball
lost hank aaron being honored tonight
for the 91st baseball all-star game on
the mound for the national league it is
max scherzer 36 years young he goes 6-3
208
three times he has won the cy young
award this is so amazing when you think
about a leadoff batter going to pitch
the bottom half of the inning and that's
exactly what ohtani's doing grounds one
right side
nice play to his right and frazier gets
the out
took a hit away from ohtani as that was
headed for that little gap and into
right field in
representing the pirates made that play
nice play by adam frazier as he and
tatis were kind of crisscrossing frazier
in front the second baseman makes the
play for out number one vladimir
guerrero jr and the pitch swagger line
drive one hop flag down to the right of
second by frazier who steadies fires to
first guerrero was out he hugged max
scherzer and that went right by max
scherzer's head and i know that was over
100 miles per hour exit velocity that's
that's uh cool and scary at the same
time 111.1
and here he is wait we just saw him at
the plate
shohei ohtani now on the mound to start
this game and
part of the reasoning has to do with the
fact that the players wanted him as a
pitcher they voted for him and also his
manager kevin cash didn't want to put
him in unfamiliar territory he's not a
reliever let him start he's had enough
to do this weekend let's do something
that he's comfortable with at the
all-star game and he'll face fernando
tatis jr the 22 year old shortstop of
the padres gets it off the end of the
pad flies it into left
and the ballpark will hold it
one down and you can see tatis just
knowing he missed one here
at cooler speed yeah here's max muncie
who climbs in and hit on the ground
right side charging in and to his right
simeon alex throws the first and muncie
is out this is season number nine for
nolan arenado his first eight
were in front of this crowd
and he won a gold glove every single
year
produced big time power numbers and he's
brought that over to the saint louis
cardinals lineup swinging a bouncer out
to shore big hop taken in by bogarts
flips on the move and throws out nolan
arenado and they go one two three end of
one here in denver
and there is no score the a-l and the
n-l and standing at first base is the
reigning national league mvp freddie
freeman
down away
here comes that moment meanwhile corbin
burns
who went
58 strikeouts before he walked any
hitters
and has 15 on the year walks judge to
lead off the inning and you look short
freddie i do i told him i was going to
look short if he got to first base and
here we are second and third nobody out
scoreless we're in the top of the second
there's marcus simeon down that's weakly
to third it's going to produce the first
run of the game judge scores on an
infield hit for marcus simeon one
nothing american league hey i heard your
son charlie got to meet tatis jr yeah i
think i'm dad of the year um that's what
i'm gonna name myself he that's all he
wanted and uh fernando what an
incredible person so good with kids uh
incredible baseball player and he's a
better person so made my son very very
happy fernando tatis jr is wearing a mic
and an earpiece out there it's short how
you doing fernando what up boys until
then we're here yeah are you having any
fun you've been smiling ever since
you have to you have to when you're
living the dream you have to robert well
now nobody on ohtani's second at bat
robbed of the hit on a good play by adam
frazier back in the first inning and he
grounds to the right side freeman flips
for the out vladimir guerrero jr how
good of friends are you two that's my
boy since childhood man we come up
together
we're kind of living almost
same life you know we grew up without
some major leaguers and it's gonna be
it's had been almost a safe ride for
both of us
[Music]
guerrero jr
has doubled
[Music]
junior with a monster shot it's
two-nothing american league you see
where they wanted the pitch and that
ball did not turn the corner and both of
them knew it the catcher
the hitter and the pitcher unfortunately
[Applause]
[Applause]
ryan reynolds the pirate center fielder
there's a blast to deep right center
field judge tracking back and he's got
it
life's good when you're 6-7
reynolds gave it a ride aaron judge with
a great running play
as he went sprinting out there by the
national league bullpen and near the 375
marker
was able to hold it in hometown all-star
hermann marquez swaying and a miss
struck him out
and marquez able to get salvador perez
and they share a smile and a laugh and
with one away the batter
will be vladimir guerrero jr guerrero
has hit two bullets including a home run
to left field that was smoked
468 feet
three pitches three swings from bladdy
jr
and that's frazier putting him away
and it will produce a run an rbi ground
out makes it three nothing al mullens
and that's gonna get through
mullins has wheels he'll score easily
it's four-nothing american league on the
rbi single from xander bogarts
i've seen the guys put the ball in play
and
good things can happen you know this
isn't
the way we typically see the game play
these days but laddie jr with two
strikes puts the ball in play drives in
a run xander bogarts
just letting that pitch travel a little
bit wasn't his best contact but it's
enough jt muto is over one tonight with
a strikeout swang at a ball drilled
center field mullins back racing back
looking
god into the bullpen in right center
field jt real newtow will touch them all
we heard you last time when you said he
doesn't hit much power yeah it doesn't
seem like the shimmering glove bothered
him all that much national league on the
board and it is 4-1
so the batter now mike zenino
he's one of the top power hitting
catchers in the game there he goes
and there's your evidence
second deck with the blast
5-1 a.l
[Applause]
well he made that look easy all right
that was just about to say that that's
easy pop see the hands
the extension
level swing and
see you later
and now they're loaded up and chris
bryant will get a chance to hit right
and that gets away
digging for the plate and scoring is
and it's a three-run game well those
things can happen even in a regular
season game where the battery is very
familiar
with each other but here you have a
situation chris bassett mike cenino now
it's bryant climbing in right side all
loaded up two hours to left
and it is cold
wow jared walsh saves the day for the
american league
oh boy that one saved at least a couple
of runs jared walsh in left field steals
a hit and a man at first and nobody out
and here's chris taylor
that pitch is passed but it goes to the
back stop and turns into an easy out at
second and the national league is still
alive ground ball should end it
to the right side merrifield has got it
and the american league has won their
eighth straight
as they win it here tonight
5-2 and in a game that lasted exactly
three hours
the american league continues its
dominance